when you finish a screenplay what is the
standard protocol of steps you'll go
through after it's done well the first
thing is to there are things to figure
out when it's done yeah and and so after
you finished the first draft it's very
sad when you've when you're new to the
job and you finish your first draft and
you think it's done and of course the
first draft you're not even listening
does the end is off in the beginning yes
it is but so the first thing that you do
is you put it aside for a little bit and
then you reread it and I tend to give it
like I read it through several times for
one I read it through the seat does the
plot have Drive I'm just focusing on the
plot are there any big holes is this
there's the piping go together the next
thing is I'll read it through each
character and say am i following the
journey of this character oh my gosh
how does she find that out why she
reacting to something she was never told
you know things like that you find out
those things or suddenly you you know
you lose sight of the character that
they're suddenly kind of falling flat
and so you start to say okay what is the
investment in their journey you clarify
each character and you make sure that
they're consistent throughout and their
voice is consistent throughout and the
final path is a theme pass where let's
say your theme is you you really can't
do anything completely alone you can't
live your life alone and lead a
productive life and then you'll be going
along and suddenly another scene says oh
you should bootstrap yourself up and
yeah well that's a valid thing to say
you know stand on your own two feet but
if it's in the same movie you're
certainly jarred so the ideal you can't
do it every time but the ideal is to
admit in each scene you advance plot and
character and theme you should scene
should advance those three things and if
a particular scene seems to be falling
flat usually one of those things has
been left out and so so I read for those
three things and when that feels pretty
good and I put it aside then but we try
and have is like a reading or you know
we sit around the table and you read it
and then you hear things that
hadn't heard before so basically it's
that you start testing the waters with
it and at first it's like difficult
because you think you're finished but if
you have a little bit of experience then
the fifth draft is far much more fun
than the first draft because you start
to discover things you start to develop
resonances and and connective tissue and
you've done the plumbing the real hard
work is done or let's say the technical
work and so that's where the fun work
starts where you can really hone moments
that you hadn't seen in the beginning
and so I think for me it's never done
until final post-edit mmm but you're
still finding things and seeing things
so you and the actors are discovering
things and you discover things in the
editing process so done is a very tricky
work well well so there's another factor
is you have to make sure where the
script that the main character is
driving it so in other words you have to
be very careful that the supporting
characters aren't the main character
though the main character isn't passive
very important and also there's always a
question of am i writing this script to
sell it or am i writing the script to
make it those are two totally different
objectives and then there's also a
reading draft so in other words with
some scripts I've written I'll write
them where they're entertaining reads so
in other words the description is as
entertaining as the dialogue because
someone's gonna be sitting and reading
it and you want them to be entertained
and delighted and ideally by the script
but there's other drafts that you're
writing to shoot like for instance with
Space Command I know I'm gonna be
shooting it then Elaine and I are gonna
be directing it and we're producing it
so then it's about well okay how are we
gonna build this how are we going to
design this who's who am i hiring to do
this role so I'm writing it for one of
the things I do is even whenever I write
a script I cast it in my mind if it's
certain actors I know I'm gonna be
hiring
I'll cast them or sometimes ugly actors
who were just very distinctive in my
head or people who in my life were a
very distinct of my head and then I'll
print out little photos of them and I'll
put them in a strip and I'll put them on
the computer in front of me so that when
I'm writing I can look at that person's
face and I can hear them in my head
and and that make that makes it come
alive but but but often when I'm writing
this nowadays see I
right now in my life I have zero
interest in development I'm not writing
scripts to be put in development and
never made I'm not writing scripts I'm
here to make stuff that's well and so
that's why I did Space Command the way
I've done it and gone directly to my
audience so for me it's very much okay
we you know we're gonna be shooting this
so how do we how do we make the costumes
how do we build the sets well it's gonna
make these look interesting this is
where my art background comes in very
handy because I love working with visual
designers and and all of that and but
like one of the things we have a
challenge we have right now is for the
second film we've shot thirty minutes of
it we have the rest of it to shoot and
that takes place on an alien spaceship a
sleeper ship 300 people have been
abducted by an alien creature and put in
hibernation so it's like okay well
that's interesting because first of all
how do we do it so it looks different
from anything we've ever seen how can we
utilize perhaps what we have already and
how can we make it look very very
interesting so we we recently put some
of our sets in storage so we're not
paying the overhead on us on a
soundstage though you know because we
had our own physical studio for several
years and so I saw we have a cave set
and in the first space command film the
first to our story that case that was
used for a mining operation on series
which is a planetoid in the asteroid
belt it was used for Mars colony and it
was used he said and then the second
film used it for ice caverns on Mercury
this is ice because there's actually a
crater on Mercury that that's so deep
that there's ice at the bottom of it
this is real this is true scientific
fact the Sun never melts the ice and so
I posited having a city made of ice
mercury has a lot of iron on it so it's
we have this religious commune that
mines the iron and ships it to the outer
planets and so there they're there and
they have a city in the ice so we used
our cave set for the ice cavern so I
thought well you know we could take that
cave set turn it sideways payment black
run LED lights along it put oblong amber
pieces of lucite in it have that be the
sleeper cells do forced perspective to
make it look like there's 300 of them
and bang we've got an alien spaceship so
now we're starting to think about how to
design that that's like
writing and what he said what was
important in terms of the hero that it
has to be the hero's journey yes because
people make a lot of mistake with their
leads they try and make them too shiny
bright and so they're boring and all we
want to see is the villain right we've
all seen those movies and and you start
giving too many of the fun lines to your
subsidiary characters right and you
don't really think through one the power
of the lead and really say okay what if
he were actually human and not all
polished and perfect because we all
secretly hate those people right and and
so you know what really is a struggle
what there's the external stuff but you
also have to give them the internal
stuff you know what what are the
insecurities what are the demons what
you know all these things and are we
really going to is that journey core
where we'll really get on board with
this guy and do we really like this man
and have his journey so I mean you I I
fell afoul of like giving my my little
side characters too much fun like with
the one that the script doctor gave me
all these notes there was one little
character where I gave him so much fun
stuff and it kept slipping more and more
over to the hero more and more until
finally when my agent read it he said I
really like it but what's this character
doing in here I said oh nothing anymore
and so the my favorite character was it
was plucked out because he didn't really
belong because it wasn't about him it
wasn't about his journey it was about
the struggle of the two leads in this
particular piece so some of us to really
say what what am I trying to say and why
have I selected this character to take
the journey with and what will I love
about and one of my favorite films which
many people haven't seen because I'm
older is a thing called Marty and the
hero was a an ugly butcher like the
writer he the writer saw himself as ugly
you know from New York a chives
panitch f-scale and he wasn't but that's
how he perceived himself and and so what
is the what's the heroic journey of his
character heroic journey of this
character is simply in the end to stand
against peers and family to go on a
quest for love because he just wants
someone to love him and people are under
you know mom doesn't want to be left
alone and the friends don't want to be
you know
feel like losers because their friend is
married just well-meaning people but in
the end they were like standing in
opposition to him finding someone that
he really loved right and and we can see
that it took minced courage to stand
against your peers and to stand against
your family it was small but it's huge
its core and so I found that an
immensely touching piece that this man
who is past marriage able age fought to
find something that he really really
wanted and but but he was full of flaws
he was afraid he he was sweaty swayed he
you know he he he was you know easily
embarrassed but he was a sweet and
honorable man and he found love and I
found that an extremely heroic piece of
writing so because we have our own
studio now the final draft of the script
is actually the final cut of the film
so we basically will write something
bring together our actors shoot it and
then refine it him in the cut and so
we'd love the fact that that allows us
to refine the story we're finding the
script refine what we had in mind and
and often they'll be discoveries along
the way so we love the entire part of
the process and a big part of it is just
when you meet brilliant wonderful people
collect them absorb them they have them
become part of your team that's what
I've done with actors that's what I've
done with our editor who's terrific you
know we just find incredibly talented
people and it's not about a zillion said
earlier you can't be a one-man band if
you were gonna just if you wanted to be
the end-all and the be-all be a novelist
because they can sit in their room they
can write they can be these pale sad
creatures but if you're in film and TV
you it takes hundreds of people and then
you need to really be a leader have a
vision be kind to your people be
supportive of them if you're a monster
if you're a nightmare life's too short
you know you can't see people well your
actors create a world your deity creates
a world yes you set designer creates a
world right but the one thing I want to
mention is our job as directors see
Alana's a better director than I am so
you know she's an actress director and
so we were very strong together as
directors we don't disagree on the set
because we see we have the same vision
but the our job is to make a safe place
for our actors so they can be vulnerable
they can be in the moment our job is to
give them the the room to do what they
need to do which is find honest honesty
and authenticity and so we see very much
eye-to-eye on that you know they have a
very hard job because they have to you
know it when you're writing you have to
like say oh this woman was betrayed and
you have to live through that betrayal
once but you expect you're a performer
to do it over and over and over and
really feel that and really be in the
moment
and that's really really hard you have
to be like an Olympian you have to be
entrained have your emotions trained
like an Olympic runner that you can keep
summoning that over and over it's it's
terrible to have an actor sobbing and
say over sound hold her sound I mean
it's a terrible thing but really
well-trained dad yeah can do that I can
pull it out all well that's why I just
have to be in class they have to be
working on their craft they have to be
able to turn it on like that to be able
to do it over and over and over so you
would say something earlier about when
you did the Space Command auditions and
you really saw people own the character
what is that when you cease maybe you
don't see it at first and that same
actor for that care and then that
there's a switch what is that owning how
do you well the only of the character is
that they seem to be profoundly and
deeply inside the character and Fragger
they know about the thing about where
either you're you know either you're
looking outside at yourself and saying
I'm this character supposed to be angry
I think I'll clench my fists and I'll
tighten my mouth and I'll be angry and
that always comes across as phony but
when a carrot when somebody owns it it
doesn't matter what they're doing with
their body or their face inside they're
very angry and one ticket may come out
loud one quietly but the camera really
sees your eyes or sees it in your eyes
and so they're they're actually feeling
it completely in the moment and that's
when you say they're owning it because
the what they're doing with I mean their
hands will naturally tense but just mean
they'll be doing this kind of thing it
means that you will when they feel that
you feel it when they don't feel that
you don't feel it at least not in the
same way and I've had you know why I've
tested that with actors and
says okay say when when when did when
were they feeling it in the class of
also at this time they were feeling out
Gore the actor and say what are you
feeling it was always the same the the
camera sees when when it's real for you
and that's owning the character and you
you often bring a really fine actor
brings a tremendous amount of their own
background and experience to it so they
not just own it but they at the moment
but they own it in complex ways there's
sense memories and fears and if it was
supposed to be betrayed they remember
when they were to somebody mocking them
and not them not be able to stop the
tears and all of that actually comes
across in the moment on screen
you